nobody knows anything that's the point
we often make on this show but it's not
totally true a few people know a lot
michael bury knows a lot he's one of the
smartest people in american finance
who was michael berry well he was one of
the very few americans who understood
that the housing bubble of the late
2000s
would lead to system-wide destruction of
our economy which of course in the end
it did
how did michael bury manage to see that
coming well unlike most
investors he's also a physician he is
trained to assess
problems empirically on the basis of
evidence rather than
theory if you're interested in the
details of what bury was saying in 2007
and 2008
read or watch the big short which is
based largely on his predictions of the
last financial crash
so with that in mind what is michael
bury saying about the economy now
well among other things bury is highly
concerned about something called
modern monetary theory mmt
mmt is essentially the belief that big
governments like ours can pay for
everything indefinitely
simply by printing more money now that's
an old idea but there's a problem with
it
printing more money causes inflation
inevitably no one denies that
it's always true what makes mmt new
and alluring is that its theorists claim
to have a solution to that problem
radically increased taxes less cash in
the system would mean less inflation if
people don't
have income to spend prices can't go up
as quickly
when you have no money you can't overpay
for goods and services
no inflation does that sound appealing
to you
to a certain kind of socialist academic
it all makes perfect sense
what does the public think of this plan
well no one's asked them because nobody
cares
but michael bury thinks the rest of us
should be prepared for the consequences
of this quote
the u.s government is inviting inflation
with its mmt
tinged policies bree wrote over the
weekend in a series of tweets
barry went on to quote extensively from
a 1974
book called dying of money which
explains what germany looked like a
hundred years ago right before
hyperinflation there changed that
country and the rest of the world
forever
as it collapsed the german economy took
on
unmistakable characteristics one was the
great wealth at least of those favored
by the boom
many great fortunes sprang up overnight
the cities had an aimless and wanton
youth
prices in germany were steady and both
business and the stock market were
booming the exchange rate of the mark
against the dollar and other currencies
actually rose for a time and the mark
was momentarily the strongest currency
in the world
side by side with the wealth were
pockets of poverty
greater numbers of people remained on
the outside of the easy money looking in
but not able to enter the crime rate
soared
accounts of the time tell of a
progressive demoralization which crept
over the common people
compounded of their weariness with a
breakneck pace to no visible purpose
and their fears from watching their own
precarious positions slip
while others grew so conspicuously rich
speculation alone while adding nothing
to germany's wealth
became one of its largest activities the
fever
to join in turning a quick mark infected
nearly all classes
everyone from the elevator operator up
was playing the market
end quote and then inevitably of course
it all collapsed quote
the deutsche marks that existed in the
world in the summer of
1922 all of them were not worth enough
by november of 1923 to buy a single
newspaper or a tram ticket
that was the spectacular part of the
collapse but most of the real loss in
money wealth
have been suffered much earlier end
quote
a book worth getting does it sound
familiar
don't think about it assures the biden
administration we've got a female
treasury secretary
the critical diversity component of
american economic policy has been
covered
rest assured but michael bury isn't
resting assured and he's not convinced
yesterday he sent this tweet people say
i didn't warn last time
i did but no one listened so i warn this
time and still no one listens
but i will have proof i warned